[Music]
again with that that crazy musical cue
it's here we're back doing the next beta
this one it's got a pillar to get in is
what it is right I think so yeah
so this is there's more to this beta
it's not just a stress test
Mortal Kombat 11 it's got classic towers
in it we can do some arcade stuff more
customization Jade and cabal Lianne in
the like last one so five characters
total now so why don't we jump into you
I guess I'll do classic towers I don't I
a literally play it like half an hour
earlier with Cabal so I don't know what
I'm doing but this is what you need to
do though is there's the gas guy the gas
master nicely so he's caustic and then
he got blade bladed and jaded I've only
played cabal and cabal husband real on
medium I'm surprised I'm surprised it it
default said easy
yeah right so these are the five
characters that are in the beta right
now so I'm gonna fight Baraka and then
we'll do some online matches and I don't
know I say I'm like a 50/50 it depends I
played like one person where they had
six wins and I beat him I was like I
feel pretty good and then I fought
someone that was like played a smarter
footsie game and was like super patient
and I was like I don't know what to do
Oh him do a thing
spicy it's made out in our tomorrow it's
out now so then I think this is also
like that like the ball hasn't been any
more comment since nine it's been a
while so that isn't a run by
yeah there's no run button so it's a bit
slower yeah I feel that I'm also
wondering if this has the different
their suits are one now okay he's in the
stress test beta there was like some
weird like you got some combos going
down this is your thing do you have them
now in this one okay good special moves
straight buzzing heck yeah
that's it though that's all I got I
think oh wait no sorry I lied here you
go how can you mark stuff so you can
actually see like comp because they have
tag you can tag up to ten yes so you can
you can get some good combos how do i
tag is triangle yeah back square
triangle look at this one backs we're
trying submit for seven damage that's
pretty good Ford Circle
it's an overhead that's definitely
important mmm maimed and mangled yeah
yeah I've been doing one on accident
myself I feel like fatal blow yep hook
slam Oh hook slam is okay it's a quarter
circle it's alright oh they got both
meet a letís so we got the fatalities in
here too so we can actually mark that oh
look at that easy one down triple down
circle can you uh can can you back for
it scored you can mark it well I can't
yeah is marketing you'll have it on your
we're trying to triangle circle this is
the beta that actually like I've been
doing that I kind of want to know how to
Pablo and did it - oh yeah if you like a
couple of hits EMG - and then you come
back that's just a Mortal Kombat
Oh like there you go yeah yeah yeah yeah
we got eight hitter heck yeah I'm ready
for online you're already you're already
feeling it is the first place okay but
you gotta be I have nothing though yes
is that a new one yeah
David Ahmadi if you're watching this I
need you to do all 10 of these beta or
five new fatalities yeah with you know
secondary fatality jet night says Jada's
life play her next well I think we'll
try okay she definitely got some range
oh yeah she got some long pokes this guy
put me in a corner and he basically was
50/50 me where he either over headed me
or he was going low super annoying help
you any way we can with crime you know
we got you now this is a closed beta
this is a beta you have to provision
into
so Kamal looks like he's just as from
just a - after that alright Cabala -
falling out goblin horde too many
questions bubbling schemes out eight you
know there it is that's fair
you got setups though you got you've got
the beginning you can know I think if
you meet her burn that toss you actually
like swim around for the which might be
you waiting for more damage
oh alright what's the other one it's a
mid-range belt forward down and forward
attacks why not
the guy before the back back forward
dump Oh
I was definitely a marathon sparring
today
Samaras always spared her life mid-range
is always I think in exit was because
like Jar is clearly like full almost
green and MIT is like anywhere in the
middle so I don't
all right back for it down forward back
forward down board right back down for
like a bean oh that meter burn that one
yeah I think you need to burn that like
spinning around a couple times
I'm not sure what the timing is for all
to burn either
I didn't know what them I think you got
do it like right Oh giving away onion
awesome beta codes I wish we could but
we'll explore as much or as far as much
as we can in that one day there you go I
think it's about like another just
running on you well second fatalities
you know that's the one we're trying to
get what you're talking about
no we did that one the second one was
gotcha
yeah but be Bruce hooks inside the mouth
mid-range backboard down forward eggs
there you go yeah that's there's a lot
there's a lot there hard I love it I
like learn learn your Mortal Kombat yeah
no switch baby yeah maybe we'll do it
later
here's hoping I'm excited to see what
that game looks like Oh gotcha
Rhys says they said in the final game of
the thing close to run is - but you
can't do that in the beta Edie Boone had
said that gosh okay that's why I've been
like double-tapping like to try to get a
- but yeah I kind of said you can't do
local play yeah I'm just really trying I
think you can play with friends on
at least I was watching sonic box played
but now it's someone who knew so I think
there might have been a way to like I
don't have that much on there okay it'll
happen
it'll come in time I didn't need to do
that but it was for swag exactly you got
to show off of it how do you guys feel
about that fatality to any minute
animation oh I haven't seen that happen
Oh like you mean postgame like like as
it freezes like it is kind of gonna walk
downtown cuz like there was something
cool about having a fatality happen than
having a character like plays at the end
I'm okay with it
have not seen Shazam he bag into the
fake house oh I don't know what the
worst part of this fatality is that he's
still looking I mean the hooks in the
mouth that means a different like there
yeah like that like freezing really
savor it yeah yeah but man that part
where the heels get ya today Jonathan
alright let's finish this off and go to
the on lines and then I'll switch it up
with Ben every now and then we'll pass
the controller I'm gonna do it are the
Move characters back Freddy Jason I mean
like the only one that's a rumored and
speculative is spawn and there's gonna
be a spawn spawn and there's also the
Terminator oh I like the robot version
or like actual Arnold like actually
honored what I'm gonna offer you up so
that those are the two live
oh yeah Oh Oh is it only off the fatal
ooh I like that combo slice my back
after its give them the uppercut just go
from max damage you know physically or
closer to any excel or injustice to for
me it feels a lot like more comment cuz
it's slower but in a good way
I'll take the 250 I don't need 8 hits
I'm just gonna get the 250 damn yeah I'm
not I'm not
hi there just checking to see how you're
doing today doing well I'm whether you
stopped in to see me to hit the shirtkin
toss and after the a problem it's worth
trying
Oh beautiful teleport dang what up right
how good to see you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah bearded kratos will be a cool
character I feel like they have to have
a guest character in some way I want I
want ash that's that's what I'm looking
for dirty Artyom can do anything
whoo thank you yeah April 23rd huge
roster of new and returning characters
the crypts epic epic crypts action I
hated the Crypt yeah it's got jump
scares so much
you see jump write it online you're
feeling it yeah why not yeah I mean we
don't need to do that tower again that's
fair unless you're gonna do Jade then I
might mess around with Jade I'll try to
okay I'll do like a couple of matches
with Cabal and then I'll pass it over my
sweaty controller to Ben to do some day
the combos flow very smoothly in this
game or do they feel for us like other
fighting games no they're pretty smooth
I mean you either know what you're
convoying into or yeah I mean there's
still some blue yellow pain but his name
is Kratos so we'll do it yeah he's won
96 games
oh it's sick I'm three and five lost 50
so the depleted why he's got like a
two-to-one right to score sore Joe
you're gonna sit here and be like oh
maybe we could have done it ours how
dare you I will take him no I'm cool I
believe in you
I don't think I think he's really sure
conviction
the man had when he picked scorpion
makes me worried
yeah it's no shaggy no bye that's fair
use it on PC and mod it in there's the
thing you know people are gonna put a
shaggy mod for this demon into it
we're trying to download me sir the
batteries letting his little brother
play like what you're selling might get
my gameplay alright i don't think oh oh
debate the debate on ham on me now he
just was critical in this version of mk2
no Danny everyone's just teleport
everywhere it's great
heck yeah I tried to fatal blow it
didn't work but it worked that dude is
just straight raw uppercutting since
goes live until 8:00 p.m. PST tonight I
think it goes live until burst i again i
wish we had beta codes to giveaway but
unfortunately we don't
oh you turn it on your lab switch oh you
try to fail global think you've got like
this locked in I got him I got him I
just fatal blow to me cuz the flag is no
bueno and you know what did he hold it
what he pulled the plug see that's why
is his win counts so high he's been
quitting what what even is this I can't
believe took them out then I'll come out
our first game we already have a key in
a poll oh man come on in a beta come on
man
come on you didn't like the Cabal in
what that they want to get cabal and I'm
upset I'm frustrated that's what he gets
were spanning I was like dude he just
spamming teleport so like you know how
he's winning he's just beating up on
people that are like trying it for the
first time and he's just doing some
straight days on I'm scorpion you know
like sometimes I get it you know you
play a couple matches you're like I need
to go to my to a steady character here
you know but no no I can't believe we
literally signed on in the first online
match for doing the stream quitting knew
he was dead ragequitting in a beta
didn't even let me do the fatality I was
gonna give him the teabag one but down
down down down Circle
oh my god man feels bad I mean he should
have saw my win-loss and reeling it he
didn't know what he was getting in for
and that's what we call the stream guys
we can't we don't know if it can get
better than that we uh we got some of
the rage quit I like how the whole point
of the story the amount near matches
Canon and that's wild to me the best of
three in that lunch
I think Destin would probably be me and
Perry now just because he's been to the
events I've gone does he plays a bunch
of like MPN and just affection - yeah
those are like his main fighting games
there's also pretty good at killer
instinct but no one talks about that
anymore in the sad
Blackey overhead you know I'd like to
fight this so he has a different huge
set thing with the sword nice low oh
yeah both only time I played more
comment with destiny I mean I've never
made it back mr. ball is awesome he's
got I miss my run what there's a lot of
stuff going on throws that's yeah that
last guy was lagging Oh watch the skull
mask
yeah lot of the a lot of the cosmetics
really I think he's inside of your head
right now
no he he literally is mauling me
I don't lie as a beta for everyone the
Venus for anyone who were she go to the
Pure Land quick get a good coat co2 is
the beta online in Europe I hope so
I don't see why I wouldn't
[Applause]
before me hey Daniel how's it going good
to see ya thanks for hanging out oh
that's good oh yeah you do have to get
the run back on this guy I feel like
yeah rest r1 and set our thief or block
like that that last round was too close
I try to chip him out - I kind of wish
um
e^x was more like Street Fighter where
you just press two buttons yeah instead
of like having a third button or like it
is two buttons but it's like a button
that's not where I want it to be I guess
the timing for Mortal Kombat stuff is
it's different in those things
[Applause]
true this is uh I think more comments
one of my most anticipated here
[Applause]
nope it's online now we've got we got
confirmation with people in Europe are
playing the beta right now okay Cabala
n-- I like them all is it hey I'll try
my best to do Jane I haven't played Jade
since I'm at nine see what we can do and
I hope I do enough to make you guys
happy when spam okay I have no answer
that we're just playing a cat mouse game
there's a lot there's a lot of trading
off happening here
their uppercut I've had a to bait him
into doing something overhead mmm dump
it I got it I got a tell you to stop
jumping why do you think I'm gonna be
private matches available I hope so I
won't be able to play with my pals
that'd be real silly I don't know about
the bait of it do what you just jumped
in when you do it if he does it's not
gonna do much stop jumping
I've premeditated you already right for
it heck yeah and now you got to get the
one back that's that's 101 he one
fatality you know did he know I'm
willing to though yeah
sorry Airport I'm willing to do it
I'll make him watch all of it I figured
him out Ben you don't you don't know he
loves to jump
he loves to wake up uppercut you know we
just have to hope that we're teaching
him to stop doing that but he seems to
not want to stop doing it so you level
up grats oh thanks yeah
[Applause]
uppercut oh nice dozen you for them
Oh is he just gonna resort to throwing
ranged attacks don't do that what
thought he was standing there what is
happening I don't know I wanted to do it
see all you gotta do is just uppercut
and sweep it's just like Mortal Kombat 3
everyone want me to do that it'll work
just just sweep them up just like Jeremy
enough times with one wheel
I wish Johnny was on the beta - Johnny's
the one I want to play the others he's
my desperation sometimes you got to be
that guy yeah I should have stayed down
there see I could have uppercutted them
now I got too confident it's okay you
got this last this is the last run for
all the marbles if you're not doing
anything anymore I know now is in my
head then it's okay this is the trait
this is this is the mind games of
fighting games it's happening right in
front of us
[Applause]
because we're playing like a kid hey
it's it's pointing us this guy online
he's got these these tactics
it's the tendencies you want me to win
or do you want me to try to combo I
think I don't know I'm basing it off
this I think that little tick there
means you'll do that much damage for the
fatal blow okay
never mind you got it I don't even
remind you I didn't remember it just
like go away I'm on this side so you
download this man to beat him - out of
him however and did both fatalities -
you could argue that if I did download
him I should have been able to combo him
I think like it's not all about like
doing flashy things by throwing off now
problem
yeah I'd say move on sorry man sorry my
dude I had my fill with you all right
I'll do one more set
assuming day or you know depending on
you to look at it and then we're gonna
do some Jade Ben's gonna do some Jade
I'm gonna take a break since I'm playing
like a kid you know hey you know I play
for the W I don't even know what that
means
aw no the plane like a kid oh it just
means like you're sweeping up we're
playing nk1
sweeping and uppercutting is the basis
that's the bread and butter for every
Mortal Kombat but you have to be able to
land that okay that's fair what's the
second fatality I did it just now I'll
do it if I can get it on this guy I'll
do it on this guy
that the one I just did was the first
one the other one I did was the second
one the one where he cuts your legs off
so the the one where it's up close is is
these is the first one technically
Scarlet's inducing kind of one plays I'm
Scarlett I have no idea what her might
see some Jade gameplay right now oh wait
did I just pick Jade oh no their Jade
yeah try the gas Matt oh here let's try
plated and jaded there you go I don't
know how he plays oh it's laggy oh it's
gonna be another fight oh I like how its
your characters I didn't even notice
that in the background that's looks like
they also added a second stage so let's
see how we do third stage let's see how
we do here with a blatant and jaded he's
playing the undead version of thing oh
yeah oh look at that connection thing at
the bottom oh it's it's not good yeah if
you get through this match it doesn't
get any better and you want to do
another one step
[Music]
uppercut punish oh that's that's a
different Oh
this may be the worst I've seen this
beta
[Music]
yeah wolf got me well in cod odds are
she's gonna do that interactable behind
her right from the start
see that's why you're a smart player
okay so the thing is Jade has that one
ability that she can actually like
piggies through stuff if she turns it on
mmm oh yeah that's right
yeah so he should connection really
isn't doing you any favors here oh yeah
it's getting the connection bottom two
do it
oh man it even the thing is kind of
lagging it yeah right okay this is like
a fatality except it's not a ballon yeah
there it is
nailed it
perfect got her dad that's two
disconnects and in a complete shutout
that's pretty good I don't know man the
first one felt better why is it lagging
we just happened to pick an opponent
that had yellow ping you could you can
find people with green ping I was
playing against green ping ER li ER
servers currently Mehta it just says
that you just joined back I kind of want
to do like a little bit of a ladder just
to kind of refresh my mind warming up
yeah yeah yeah I mean we're still
showing off date so it's all good yeah
sure in katanas in the game no that'd be
hilarious it should go down though I
mean it'd probably be a good show of how
many people have gone in and downloaded
this or a pre-ordered it or whatever
yeah yeah hello
this isn't katana look normal without
masks she doesn't have the teeth it's
just Melina it's just Melina yeah we're
gonna do Jay we're gonna do a ladder
first this is I think it's and conquer
and then in classic yeah you are not
connected to the combat server so I'm
gonna try again later
did we just lose connection yeah maybe
we can bug and replug if that doesn't
work I'll just restart the game and see
what happens
the meantime can we can customize while
we while we wait
oh there's who see what I took the HDMI
first it's all good let's see what what
Jade's got lets her together a jade okay
there's the unmask - Jade yes we can we
can choose different masks you got some
cool cosmetics going on oh you just go
with that one if we want hey no masks
yeah all right down
that's the girl breathe we got Christina
says uh hey good luck guys thanks for
hosting stream yeah no worries thanks
for stopping by Hank now for asking
questions our brutalities in the move
list no J bogey not from what I saw at
least because usually the brutalities
are under fatalities right yeah yeah
they're not there at all
fatality calm s turn her down I don't
know if it's actually bad you should
just be us did you make the Jade of your
choice
I'm messing around with a little bit
we're gonna get some tranch I also like
kind of looking at all the different
scales oh my god
this is very injustice here though yeah
this is totally from injustice to kind
of digging this this red like the red
going with the green so I'm gonna go do
that sounds good a little Christmas yeah
I'm gonna check out Mortal Kombat and
see if there's anyone saying that it's
down or anything I don't think it is
we'll do that pole vault that sounds
like a good time a little bit of a spark
oh I think it's good do that nitro kick
okay cool so do you think you got to get
exit the game well we'll find out here
in a sec okay I reconnected you but
just read it out so alright just
restarted closes a game we'll go real
quick Oh Jason a striker is playing we
should uh challenge him to a match yeah
challenge giant bomb want peace Jake
said someone here that's in chat that
might be in both chats tell him we want
to fight
oh yeah the Jade's stuff kind of looks
like a lightsaber a little bit
I like how much it glows it's a good
call do you think Molina is in mp11
I hope so George I played a lot of
Molino is my main and then k MK 10 oh
really
yeah well there we go she's the one I
got pretty good with or she's the one
like the one I mainly got good with
everything else was kind of like never
really dug into some of the others I
mean like I played some ones DLC
characters and whatnot because I was
doing coverage and gameplay for it but
not going easy oh do it didn't say my
thing that's fine I'll just use one
these ones Royal Guard naughty the ones
that Jerkins one looks like you're
mainly using your staff maybe the one in
the middle is kind of like a hybrid
thing maybe I'll try this assassin one
it looks like it's got a lot of cool
pull tricks so is variation to think
that like no matter what you just have
like in online matches or is that
something that like that you can turn
off because remember having justice had
long you could turn off equipment or
whatever I don't know if that's like a
lot of things you're gonna have to like
learn yeah well I guess that's not true
that's the same as MK 10 they had three
variations right so yeah they have three
default ones here but I don't know if
like maybe in tournament play you can
only use one of the three defaults case
because you can pick different abilities
you lost a clan I lost around we're
seeing I'm dead wrong only Jade all
right why I guess we were fighting
against a few oh it's we got ladders we
got betrayal
you know what sure tag it there's a lot
here yeah you got some long I'm just
gonna tag everything that I got that's a
special move fatal attraction that's
pretty good xoxo Kimmy you think they
did that on purpose and not here right
mark the overhead cuz that's gonna be
important
that's another overhead and let's make
sure we get down down from anywhere all
right and then they do remember the
other oh yeah
back forward down boys square pull down
don't forget that our two as your block
because I kept forgetting and our one is
your variation
yeah that's a good one I like that I
like it the X triangle triangle down
your eyes how can you see now
Oh No okay it's like really your eyes
how can you see she's got she's got some
good stuff going dude of course we gotta
look at moves Dave we've never played
Jay
just like I've never played a ball I had
to figure him out okay so we got back
just uh this is that the flag nice any
luck for something excuse me remember
how to do awesome oh sure yeah get it
back forward I don't have I don't think
I have one I can just straight all right
sue this does this the second one it's a
personal
[Music]
can't hear you over the sound of alright
so you guys see the other one I don't I
don't know if I've seen the other one
yet yeah so right now we are just going
through the ladder Ben is repolarizing
or familiarizing himself with Jade
because he hasn't played Jade yet so
this is kind of like the warm up before
the online stuff yeah I don't want to
like go online and not have any food
hey trills now saying new sidewalks got
the best date alone again I'm really
happy he's in the game I think it's sick
that like the old boob is in the sword
yeah and he comes out or display well I
think it's the old noob it's how I
oh it's it's noob is the main characters
apparently people didn't know that I
didn't know like the only time they ever
we do it is I was getting high load in
the corner buy Jade stuff that's my
favorite I do there's got to be a
brutality there I feel like there I got
I feel like there's a big ecology where
we're sorry like a stage fatality if not
a fatality
yeah so that's like double overhead and
there's like one way you can like solo
after there's the shadow good see that's
that's what I'm looking for I'm trying
to find that shadow kick because you
know you can also
whoa smear
oh I can't do it cuz I tried to do it
the environmental I just spun me
spinning me clothes poor poor down
forward
dammit that's that's on my eyes I wanted
to see what her irregular victory screen
was yes you go see everything nailed it
perfect harvies are calculated mm-hmm
defend them all right so I think if I do
that as a fatality in this fight I'm
feeling pretty okay okay
Splash Damage scarlet curious if like
enough people played Devorah them
surprises I don't know this isn't
character is I guess it makes sense that
that came back fell 11 from 10 but I
could have lived without I don't really
care for Jackie I don't really care for
I'm excited Jackie's there I'll
carefully Devorah well this game have
pay2win loot armor system that's tough
you can turn off any way to do this oh
you're back turbo dead oh yeah the black
the back flip off the staff Li's dope
pretty cool she got some reach I don't
know how you like something you played
good put seeds it's hard to get in but I
don't know what to punish and what's not
safe and stuff like that like that's got
a not be safe yeah that like staff yeah
oh wait this is the stage that has the
really cool interactive one yeah how do
you bring her over try to do it think
it's right here the chainsaw yeah no
surprise that wasn't like a fatal zero
right well we tried a fatal blow you
well no I just think that you're going
for the ground we're close okay Pat RL
win I don't know about that
there's not it's not pay2win loot I'm
just saying that like you have armor in
this game or like you get here just like
you wouldn't injustice but like it's not
something you have to have like
fundamentally on and matches that make
sense it's not pay to win though because
you end up picking the variations it
doesn't really matter I don't even know
if they have that system in this game
you know you know how injustice had like
legendary armor and stuff like that but
you could like equip I don't even know
but I know for sure you could turn that
off so I never thought of that as like a
thing oh no I press the wrong button
okay fine this girl look like you did
you did all the things I'm ready to
embarrass myself against real people
sick let's do it yeah
oh that's not necessarily true got a war
I don't think so I mean like injustice
has DC heroes obviously which people
would probably gravitate more to and the
story was actually pretty good
but yeah like I I thought MKX was pretty
good pretty solid I had fun I had fun
playing Alien and Predator gotta Wars
always in this chat you just can't let
him faze you guys if he doesn't like a
game that's what I've come to learn
everyone's entitled to opinions but you
know like he's not being like overly
like I don't know aggressive I guess can
you use the dodging shadows heart says
the Manuel Lopez yeah that thing is
pretty good it it basically makes it so
you projectiles like phased through you
so that you you know you can't get zoned
out basically 0 & 1 you got a good
chance here I'm running go Ben goes
there's great Fox appreciate how I've
got a war but not this one that's very
well appreciate the the backup though
I'm curious this is gonna work out this
game is not pay to win though gotta
worry you crazy you know I don't think
you should know pay to win in this game
I mean if you want to like go to the
streets and fight with your like earned
tiers of gear go for it but I always
just played me and my variations versus
another opponents variations and that's
where that's it you know you learn Jade
fatality yet he knows one of them did
you memorize them down down forward down
circle anywhere I think is what it is
you know the other one did backboard
down port square back forward down
forward yes we're okay cuz I press
that's the one that you didn't do yet
that's the one you didn't do that oh
cool you got a 73 okay I'm just accounts
like I'm accepting them and they keep
turning me it's green it's green pain
what you know why the person that's six
and six understand it
let's block button the same yeah let me
fight you I don't get why people like
think that this game Zepeda win game
I've never heard that about an MK ever
but sure if that's what you guys want to
think or believe he's gonna play
yay assassin while you're playing random
selection jade no let's let's try this
one okay so looks dangerous that one's
crazy
you got this as run the second Sakura
yeah but mr. burns you don't have to
play against those people in that way
you literally that would be a mode that
you can choose to do if you want to but
if you don't you can straight-up play
people that do not have gear on that's
always been the case so I don't get why
you think that that is a thing
so maybe picking us reason [ __ ] is not
the good call cuz now you don't know
you're moving I don't know what that got
there's a bold choice gotten it really
was and it's not paying off well he said
that move I guess there we go but Harry
yeah I thought the guy was taunting me
that entire time ooh nice oh I don't
have a jump what was that I could do
like a short hop oh I do have a jump
though as it turns out down down
backward circle anywhere okay there's
they did this shadow
yeah over stuff is just counters now you
are the Royal Guard now to get back and
like a fighting game mentality yeah
that's fair that's what I did against
that one guy I just tried to play put
these in up with us ooh that's made it
safe oh no it's yeah you got it full
screen nice okay that's fine I do in
fatalities that was like this guy isn't
worried didn't watch matches I'm so
injustice though yeah like this little
thing after I might back out just so I
can pick a different set up because that
one was that one was lame I wasn't
feeling it I why I picked Royal Guard
not expecting it to be a bunch of
counters well no worries little cat
scratcher better late than never
are you fine the same guy yeah
do you have some really cool attacks and
I think she'd be really fun if I spent
more time we don't know what the DLC
characters are yet yeah we know King's
house
yeah and if you preorder no oh
bring that boat Oh nicely nothing might
this work oh yeah there's a lot of stuff
you can do off air air attack like
counter so that moved was frightening on
my new favorite thing there's a
follow-up though for you're a little
staffing so they're supposed to be but
it's not taking okay no I can't detect
Wow
okay so for the be a fatal blow is how
much that throw did which is pretty
that's pretty good yeah there's also the
Jack not necessarily but they did did
they actually proper now so I know
there's no like I don't know if like
nobody said it's a mansion for the king
okay
okay I just saw the trailer and I'm like
dude after playing MK 10 there are so
many characters in that thing that like
it could have been anyone you know Alex
yikes yeah maybe Jade isn't my person
yet guy knows what's up yeah the
follow-up isn't going okay take take me
away oh wow that's sick with it yet it
was yeah so he's chipping go out with
some fire yeah I do want to try to
follow it when someone slow cuz he was
one that I did play it but maybe another
day got a war if you're getting bored
you can always just come another day
there's a wee stream when it's Friday if
you guys know against wildlife do
different things today we're checking
out MK online beta I think tomorrow
we're just gonna be helping or not
helping but we'll be hosting the
borderlands like panel whatever that is
at so check that out you're going gas
masters the regular one cabal and yeah I
think it's the closest to what scorpion
has a lit here literally is lit right
it's true
I appreciate that they're not
significant ratio release April
do something it's 20 something like
ndividual which one are you the second
one okay you're already feeling it
looking good
yup yup that must be like this yeah so
know how to do that feel like hit that
move that he's doing I want to do
cooling of the back circle for you the
hook but it's a low
no oh he could have fatal blow to you
but he did not he was waiting for me to
do it so we'd have the opening that's
fair he's been pretty good about
quantity so it's a little bit inside
that little like divot and you can
pretty much kill at the fatal blow it's
okay you still have yours he doesn't
have his anymore you know already going
way better with Kaval Dan was on Jade
yep oh he has a parry thanks oh oh he's
not expecting the raw - in what we
trying to counter you again cute one of
those again yeah so if you do those
moves that you're doing into like the
quarter circle back circle you'll end
with that throw that you can save like
what was the input I would say I'm just
gonna do it alright let's just take it
that's their guy take the win we can oh
now we have a pair we have a fair fight
for round three resonate no evil I mean
it's our first day playing so you know
if you're not into the lack of combos
you can tune into a pro stream or
something like that's not what these
streams are about I mean most of us are
pretty like I would say like average
above average at games but you know
we're definitely not pro players we're
definitely not here to do like crazy
combos like being able to do some of
these are
my opinion like having a seven hit 200
damage that's a victory my book Alton
and I think that that's quite quite good
compared to not to undersell your Jade
gameplay this is going way way better
than earlier last last match so we got a
close match guys playing some some real
real fighting games right now
yep yep triple down circle yeah we got
up we do fatalities here for Eva got up
the Cabal might be the one for me right
now cuz I feel like I can pull a now
file oh I'm terrible at smash bands get
a smash though I'm already I'm pretty
sure both of us could land a strike on
you resident no evil there's no such
thing as I don't think you would P
either of us oh yeah I'm like almost
pause I think that's like beating us
that's one thing but like I don't think
I don't think you would go unscathed I
will literally jab you actually in this
game you get chip damage so thick
texture you know there's no way that
they would survive but hey you know what
I guarantee we're gonna play this on
community Fridays if you come back oh
that comes out you can smash you better
work resident oh you will come back in
April come bring it those those words
that you're talking about and join the
lobbies yeah that's what kind of what
community Fridays is there for follow up
later on and yeah I love it
have you ever seen that like ESPN does
this thing where they kind of do the
same thing where they like take people's
tweets like you know about a certain
sport like let's say football right yeah
and the guy will say like oh yeah I how
did he miss that field goal I totally
could have made that field goal and the
best part is they left like they they
show them the tweet and then they make
them kick the field goal and when the
guy kicked it he literally kicked it
five yards into the ground yeah and then
he had to apologize I want some of that
I want that in gaming that's that's
really like more like stream cache
that's what I wanted
oh I hit the wrong foot that's okay he
tried a fatal blow and you block it
that's already a big win oh you just do
it oh I was trying to go for the cactus
to finish it don't think I thought you
were trying to fatal blow switch to
generate I can try playing gate in that
in a second you can I I thought I'd be
able we're both deck technically from
what I'm seeing better at the wall but I
haven't played Jade either so you know
we'll see I could my session could go
equally bad you really want that cactus
huh do I want to practice a lot like you
reposition him back in the corner for
one thing I know it I can't get the oh
no it was I was like heat you got a kid
yeah you know one more hit you probably
put them through the fatal blow blender
alright so one one I 100 a song a song
come on come on dude you gotta do it you
know how to do it alright he's been
playing what didn't hear which i think
is really everyone fighting game he's a
cactus hugger that's where our mac for
life or max a pretty dope character I
like what they did with them in 10
I could try scorpion but oh that's not
true Rock ATL look at Jaden cabal
they're pretty like Morocco
I don't you play whatever you want yeah
but go cabal it's really fun I saw
someone to ask for scorpion maybe I'll
go are you the fire breather chain
reaction
I believe so because it's got that that
grab that I really like
yeah this is a good look Dan the
interactions without sides is great yeah
they're pretty cool I like this one
because it's got that that hammer and
it's also got the chainsaw because
that's very important to me
do you prefer footballer Dana I haven't
played Jade yet but I I played it one
too cabal in three right with three I
believe yeah and so I just have a
nostalgia for cabal and oh so he just
want to get that follow-up that's a
great throw oh yeah
Oh a little late but I like it I like
where your head's at we're gonna get
there we don't have stuff so you can
punish them you actually want him this
is going back to you so that you can do
the sick teleport on them Oh put that
fire up get back oh yeah okay makes it
tape oh you're actually lucky that he
didn't fatal blow you there okay
I knew you'd go for it again there was a
Khaleesi this is where you punish the
you punish the spammers ya know you want
to sand that distance game not today
oh that's fine the team the team need
the teeth oh wow the follow-up is is
real can you not do anything after that
you can yes
really I don't going I don't know when I
get that just feels like you're getting
but you should get a bigger payoff out
of that I feel like yep good
old-fashioned uppercut sometimes I just
enter with the uppercut even though you
can get more hits because like the
damages is better let's go make a joke
about it being like old school like it's
all Mortal Kombat thing to do but no
it's still very good still very
effective but it does push them all it
does push them away from you which is
why I think people don't do it because
they want to just get back in that oh
they're gonna be a range attacked or
something else just know that if you
teleport then make sure to e.x oh yeah I
try to get the finisher because okay I
did it and it put me in the perfect
position I'm sorry it's okay it's
alright it was a good call I mean feels
bad sorry okay yep give him a giver that
they Oats almost I like it
I don't think you can actually you can I
think you can I think you might be able
to I thought it was so sweet you hungry
lovely bird oh good blocks way to not
want to punish right away I would have
pressed buttons for sure
you didn't see me coming oh he didn't
back I'm pretty sure I can follow that
that tell us what about the x1 just like
get over here oh my god let's just whip
a whole bunch
it's the footsie game bigfoots these
battles okay alright still in it to win
it
oh no and then punish good oh good I
think I think it's probably I'm going to
pass it off though
all right Jamie way to go I don't know
if I can give Jay to go against this guy
though oh crap all right I guess it's a
scorpion no no no no rematch right oh I
should character selected let's just I
get to try everything I don't know half
of these moves but it's alright it's
what you're already in it you already
got you already got a combo down there
not backwards head hadouken how do I
tell oh oh it's that one okay aw dang it
I was the first empty game you played
the first Mortal Kombat I played it at
my friend's house because my parents
were like there's no way we're buying
you the game that's creating the
electronic ratings board for video games
so I had to go to my friend's house
I'm willing to do it you're playing a
different scorpion right now heck yeah
I gotta make that save cliff Morocco
frog is a pretty good size
[Music]
how's the baby piece you only know it's
actually not on PC only on xbox and
gives four below just do it
oh the - movement turn into a skeleton
that one how do I do that
it's forward backward X you got that
punch out in the middle leg kick but I'm
into it
[Applause]
oh yeah share just go flying I love it
but what do you say it was for backward
acts counterintuitive oh no it's okay
I'm sorry I'm like forward backward ex
why would anyone do that I'm thinking
like the opposite side of the screen and
my mind is a mess yeah you're fighting a
different scorpion perfect it wasn't
back for Dex Oh for the fatality no no
for the it should be alright let's go
fight someone else yeah I got your sweet
revenge yeah it was good wait this guy
is playing different what is going on I
don't know what are some combos for Jade
I just figured out are there any sexy
outfits for Jade I got that like so the
the combo is trying to do the whole time
the witch was like the biggest biggest
one was like yet it starts off with back
triangle then square the triangle then
square again and for some reason it
wouldn't pick up okay I'll give it a go
yeah see how it goes
come on my dude or how is he level five
with what his own one duh does this beta
carry over from the closed beta
why are you declining man Baraka is buff
I've never been a Baraka fans I just
never played them Barack is a thick boy
oh yeah he's real Leslie I think it's
Goro
oh he's not as thick showers or my man
bow ride all right oh heck yeah farting
Cho baby I hope he shows up again
don't want to play of course you decline
that's fine was that the person we've
fought before
no they just have yellow ping I was
gonna decline it anyways to be honest uh
it feels slower than a little slower
right now but as chap mentioned earlier
Ed Boon has said like there's gonna be
like a - which is like kind of - to make
up for the rut lack of rush dang this
guy is twenty six and eight I'm not
gonna be a good J time but figure it out
I still think that not being easy this
game of speed is more comparable to nine
it's not exactly nine but it feels a lot
like nine which makes me very excited
about it
all the guy that says whoopsies yes I
hope he shows toasty toasty yeah yeah oh
I need that combo how do I do that combo
game
Oh his is stylish thanks gone I'm
already intimidated did he skip the
intro to his tie skipped it that's the
first Power Move we can do it match
thanks ring info anytime happy to help
holy he lit his dagger on fire what is
going on
it's on fire okay you have a follow-up
oh there's the follow-up so he's got the
phone oh he's got he knows what he's
doing
what all right I think that might have
just been a like a actual game
disconnect yeah he would have destroyed
did you say follow okay so II X it goes
into a kick into the intellect Oh get
over here and yeah into something else
now the room was 10 minutes late 10
minutes late with our livestream is
there a combat cast today and we didn't
know isn't it usually at 1:00 it's
usually way later yeah if it does it's
usually like a 1 or 2 PST and that guy
would have swagged on me
Larry oh not for another 50 minutes is
it actually today yeah it's not a thing
that you guys know is actually happening
cuz I haven't seen anything about it
feeling like daggers on fire right mmm
lit
I could just probably go to like ed
booms Twitter and find out what's going
on oh that's weird - I wouldn't I don't
understand how you like didn't get your
oh my because I don't do I want to fight
this guy no there isn't a PC beta
yeah that's that's why oh that why if
you pre-ordered it on Steam you don't
get a beta code because there's no beta
on the PC they said on Instagram it was
at 3 p.m.
retro maybe hit up the slacker rule see
you'll see what's going I'll see what's
going well we'll end by 12:30 so we'll
we'll have we'll have time to do it you
know if they're showing anything I
anything off guys Jesus you must give us
Deena throw the sweet deets today at one
sweet okay thank you for that yeah tell
us yeah if you guys have any info in
terms of like what they're showing maybe
that'd be pretty cool go to Ed Boon
house and asking Yacht Club announced
their new game oh yeah it looks very
good with white ninjas okay but have you
think katana zero yeah yeah I'm very
excited it's changed a lot
[Music]
I'm just trying to do a combo bro
all right oh we both with our uppercut
stick
oh yeah Hamed counts tomorrow and
tomorrow today between the okay so this
happening cooing no teases so what's in
it though but I'm excited either way
[Music]
[Applause]
baby-talking before
yeah I'm kind of down with a slower
we're set for it
all right I'm playing to win because I
know I'll it early don't know how to
play her dude play to win that's fine no
shame one at all the beta is out for
anyone who pre-ordered
you think it's get her over here goes
our trade number cut co2 I get a double
uppercut back port down quark where the
character being shown today will be once
we've been revealed but not shown so
what's the move list Jade what's your
move list our select a new fighter
that's fine so should I play Baraka hey
give Baraka go he's pretty fun hmm what
the see Graywolf we haven't seen in the
like the one with like the dash
[Music]
all right did you prep the boys for the
combat cast Oh
our boys anything back
I didn't play Jayden mk9 I'll be honest
I need to get them a tasty give them a
taste of the awesome day vitality I
don't know it I don't even know parathas
I skipped it whatever I don't even know
how to put Rocky like this will be
interesting I think I got a co is too
late and somehow that way
there we go off the air so that's good
and get it again
I download so you have to pee or the
game and then you should be able to find
it in the store it back triangle what's
his back back fee to some personalities
if we knew any off the top of our oh
yeah the uppercut one anyone has the
sick
did they disconnect oh no no just
getting deseed all wasn't a very good
display of Baraka anyways that's fine
well we all got to start and learn these
characters again something cuz like
Baraka wasn't in X Jade wasn't in acts
the ball wasn't in X remember it's a
beta y'all it's gonna happen
move the jams ooh
yellow paying are you declined that's
fine I would have to they probably see
it to sort of like you know I don't want
to fight a yellow paying either spark
brutality you like it's being streamer
it's on on life maybe it's our
connection but I've ever watched and
I've played it feels it feels pretty
good yeah I think I've went in the match
goes through it's fine it does feel
slower though so sting I guess what
Brock go go what is this one
well I'm submitting brutality makes
sense Flag Day someone really the norm
or banner stuff so I think more banners
downtown no I don't think they're what
motaro he'd be interesting I don't know
if I play him very much but I got Johnny
and Cassie song I'm pretty stoked
your desertion is gathered how is that
starlit I am now show kinds of white
hand oh oh you got some exposition some
story happening army didn't get the
comer up here in digital copy so I think
it just gives you access to it oh that
was nice so you have to like find it in
like on PSN or an Xbox
you didn't get his fatal blow closer oh
I didn't press block oh man I press
together like a scrub where our thoughts
on Wolfenstein Youngblood are they
pulling baby soft Far Cry need on type
of thing I think it's gonna be a good
time I'm safe I just want more
Wolfenstein in fact its co-op this time
around is James blowing at these two I
mean you gotta mix it up every now and
then you can't just stick with what
you're going the whole time the double
boot is a very strong move to the
Broca's damage is very high I think so
it looks like oh that's too slow
yeah he's got if you raise your eyebrows
high enough you'll win Troy whipped it I
will play her again players not with
Baraka
you mix it up you go back to cabal ya
sake of all is the gym I'm going back to
my boy cabal I do like how next opponent
they said no they didn't want to come on
man come on I didn't play with my real
character oh that sucks
come all just feels really good like
that first variant feels just like you
didn't nein yeah way to do it scorpion
still feels really good I wish to like I
after seeing that one guy do the pull
off that one call I was pretty cool
pretty nice combo I wanna I want to know
more of his like new combos Apollo I
think that's what one of them is a
revenue yeah yeah I think I think so
because someone said someone in their vo
back to him was like you're revving into
something something yeah black napkin
why are people declining
I got we got like full game bars like
good-looking match COBOL is fast yes he
is I was like how he's got like a good
mixer like command grab type of things
you know I don't why they wanna play
game I don't even care if I get wrecked
there's no Johnny in this one if we
could polish I wouldn't be playing
anything else I just did Johnny Cage all
the time Cabala Jade are both red means
unless you yeah unless you end up
kicking like one of the ones that like
to look different no sub-zero sub was my
boy mk2
Spears a good time am I gonna ice the
floor am I gonna ice you ice the floor
uppercut slide well they're looking for
the friends they can practice oh that
could be true you can play towers like
that's - oh is it because theythey
seater or whatever and then they're like
oh we got a research for you maybe
Special Forces desert tumor that's a
good outfit for Jade I'm gonna do it I
missed it
sniper for life gonna go
yeehaw you can get a year off scorpion
isn't playing up in a scorpion earlier
stop pressing button so my favorite move
is
[Applause]
gotcha there you go why do you have so
long laughter you if you press the need
to burn button instant okay I'll help
you get out of combos we did that
earlier we can try we can always because
I'm not being precise
so the block and interacting it's not
liking me but you gotta like like after
they got like a little bit of great
God every time so with the heel
I don't remember what his other one was
I mean at this point that's the new one
so like what we're just going hard on
the core down forward square maybe
possibly you might be able to pull up
them and you in the fight if you really
want some
[Music]
oh I knew it
[Music]
she printed on fatal blow I like it good
some pretty solid to connect again
double uppercut guys how do I throw
again the two is it about that okay yeah
we're gonna I got a UH gotta get my full
arsenal out because he's definitely
dagger high-low to there they're on top
of that Jason what happened to x-rays so
they are they're like off like on the
Wanderers now so they happen in the
middle of like if you meet certain
conditions and a certain finish
oh there it is 100% worth nail this
there's a brutality for those asking
happened to me but it's okay yeah
one-one just get there run get the run
back she's got a mixing some throws this
person is blocking because I'm spamming
I'm not doing enough high-low I but I
don't know his high-low combo
unfortunately when all else fails go for
that grab
[Music]
yeah
I think now you get like more x-rays
because it's it's you get x-ray moves
based off of your finishing like cocaine
is hiking McCain Americans are gonna
support there you go
you came to the right place this Jade's
tearing it up if you get the baby out
you have to preorder during the game get
you into the closed beta
read me he's read me he's figured me out
that's right I get it
last round of status apparently there is
a reality for the ball where to do his -
and then you put the button down it'll
are going to you Taddy try it we can try
to keep that in mind for me and get down
a little bit match
[Applause]
- you've heard digital even just going
find the download and the sword go oh he
took the armor I was hoping that if I
could land a fiddle globe I could try to
do what people wanted I was literally
gonna hold all four buttons I mean we
could try to do it in the ladder
well this is the other one okay forget
about it all right I can try to do it in
ladder brutality or
do it do one more run back and then we
can check it out
it is it is 12:30 if I win we're just
going out on the win if we lose then
we'll probably try to do the thing okay
I just don't know how to I don't know
how to get in there but it is like I
won't be honest I probably be too busy
playing or watching that's those you
know what those a follow up and I'll
take you cannot play the beta offline
versus which is real unfortunate and I
wish you waiting - but swords you can do
ladder matches you can do customization
and you can play
[Applause]
like kind of casual matches against
encourage one thing come up with a
switch I think it's the same kind of
forms out everywhere else the data
should be live
oh come on Kenny brutality
I don't remember it really the other one
you try to go all right so let's quickly
try to get to the thing all right
that brutality yeah I'm down I want to
see it so as I run I hold some type of
button that's that's Mary hold the Box
down like Oh ad just hold that button
down yeah because that's what people are
saying
it's like spamming we'll come on three
characters are in the base game I guess
we can just go off of this and say maybe
the amount that are in like on this menu
oh the character select I've encountered
it up but that's probably a good rough
idea oh you think that the Deadpool
thinks that it's the like Jax or Liu
Kang yeah one of the characters Kung Lao
they exist that we're not gonna like go
into it
now this is just a good excuse to like
mess around and try to figure stuff out
while we work towards with a brutality
deathly release to someone today it's
coming out on the switch like that's
this unless I'm I'm like making that up
and lost my mind 25 to 29 there we go
oh you bring up gasps master football
yes yes he has it uses the gas once I
got to remember to kill them with the
thing I don't even know how much damage
it does though that's like earlier I
mean you just kind of like spam it I
guess until it works make them very very
busy okay there you go look at that meat
man wowser nailed it yes that's good I
guess that's how you get that brutality
off you just do one and do another one
yeah holy smokes put that one up clip it
yeah let's get out of here that's a good
way ready for this combat cast thank you
all for tuning in we really appreciate
it well it's a GameSpot live Monday to
Friday 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
that's been Janka I'm Eric Tay come back
tomorrow we're just going to do a
hosting of the Borderlands kind of like
panel that they're having at PAX so
check that out tomorrow 11:00 a.m. and
you guys will be back you and John Luke
for community Fridays yeah they're gonna
be doing do you know if you're starting
through those I think we are okay so
they're gonna play through as many or
all of the MK games before MK 11 comes
out so they'll probably do a couple each
stream so come back Friday for that and
yeah I think that's pretty much it
apparently we're being told that if you
do the gas attack and hold a button that
also does 100 slimey hold button button
I like it all right anyways thank you so
much send us out of here
[Music]